the Roman period has long since ended
but the world is still in a state of
fragmentation as a new era of rebuilding
sweeps across the Western world new
states and nations start appearing and
cultures from across the globe begin to
mix like never before through this time
of cultural exchange the Nordic people
played an important role in determining
its outcome however with this came a
period of conflict that the world was
not prepared for this was the age of the
Viking
you
the history of the Vikings can be
somewhat bias in nature due to the fact
that they themselves left behind very
few texts discussing their own history
in the majority of the documentation
that can be found is based on the
recounts of monks and victims of the
Viking invasions as you can imagine to
them these were a brutal race of people
purely responsible for the devastation
of their country at this time but
through Viking legends and mythology
which were passed down from generation
to generation eventually led the world
to the true story of the Scandinavian
people the term Viking has often been
used over the years to particular an
image of a group of barbaric plunderers
that plagued Western Europe however in
reality these people are actually an
elite class within North Society a
collection of traders explorers
seafarers consider lers and sometimes
invaders while there is much speculation
around the reason for the Nordic peoples
sudden rapid expansion into the
neighboring countries most argue it may
have been due to conflict over land and
lack of resources in the 9th century the
people of Scandinavia had recently
discovered the use of sails and given
their geological location they quickly
became masters of the craft and this
enabled them to travel all over the
world settlements were an important part
of Viking society not only were they
traders and explorers but they also
started to settle everywhere they could
settlements were the basis of their
community and the foundation for their
livelihood another part of this society
the platon and temple role were the
Norse gods and myths they believed
heavily in science symbolic meanings and
superstitions and the daily life
included ceremonies rituals beliefs and
interpretations of the world around them
after the withdrawal of Rome from
Britain and 1480 there was no one that
had claimed to the land so it eventually
came down to whoever had the largest
army they were the ones who were able to
carve out and hold on to the more
desirable pieces of land over time
political structure began to form and
eventually boundaries were drawn by 650
ad a number of small kingdoms have been
established by leaders who are now
calling themselves kings of the
respective areas but over time the
smaller or less successful kingdoms were
absorbed into the others either through
conflict economic shift or by marriage
by the 8th century four kingdoms
remained Northumbria Murcia East Anglia
and wizards
although a predominantly multi-ethnic
society including Britain's descendants
of ancient Rome and many others the land
was dominated by the anglo-saxons it was
a wealthy land but it was a divided land
especially between the four rival
kingdoms and this was all very appealing
for the Vikings who took advantage of
the situation of a divided England
carrying on from the previous century
England experienced an influx of Vikings
in the ninth century and over time these
kingdoms fell to the invaders one by one
who set up a selection of anglo-saxon
puppet rulers in each Kingdom the only
one that survived was wizards King
Alfred the Great managed to maintain his
kingdom of Wessex and not only survived
but he managed to fend off the Viking
invasion
it's here during this age of transition
that Assassin's Creed Valhalla takes
place the player takes on the role of
Abel leading the Norse people to a
foreign land in search of a new home
the year is 1873 ad a volleyed fellow
Vikings from Norway to establish a
settlement in England as part of the
Viking expansion across Europe there
will be deadly raiding parties massive
battles and a settlement to be built
while using diplomacy or force to
interact with other Viking clans all
during the ninth century
across Britain Norway and Scandinavia a
Valls arrival is met with the resistance
from King Alfred of Wessex in the Saxons
who will do everything in their power to
drive the Vikings from the land alfred
denounces them as heathens and desires
to be the sole ruler of a civilized
England shifting england's balance of
power and expanding influence through
diplomacy will likely make more friends
than using pure brute force every
political alliance made combat strategy
employed and choice will alter the
journey it is during this time that a
board meets the hidden ones and joins
the fight against the order of the
Ancients
Assassin's Creed Valhalla is due to be
released in the holiday of 2020 which
generally means sometime around October
and December I'm genuinely excited and
concerned about the release of this game
as previous editions have caused the
loss of countless hours doing well I
don't even know time just disappeared I
like to make these sort of videos before
the release of titles like this because
the research helps me truly immerse
myself into the world in this situation
I had enough information for around
three hours with the video based on the
history at this time but it decided to
taper it back to keep it interesting for
everyone else
truth be told after six weeks have
locked down I'm starting to look a
little Viking myself just a bit more of
a nerdy dead bod Viking go anyway I hope
you've enjoyed this video and I'll catch
you in the next one
Cheers